I was watching the WNBA prank and uh
it was a while did you feel bad at all
um
so the crazy thing about it is I went to
three games so that's that was the
funniest thing yeah the fact that when
you get kicked out of the Minnesota one
and then you call cat oh yeah yeah cat's
my boy a cat backs him he's like nah
he's good let him go back in there to
prank the female team see I thought I
had more pool he's a franchise player I
was like yo cat you can't tell security
but uh you know it was the NBA but um we
actually went to a phoenix game where
Brittany Greiner and I'm looking
because I had a shirt with Vladimir
Putin and then in the back uh he had
like a weed symbol but I was out there
game and I was gonna he was there but
like I genuinely had a really good time
like it was I I generally just had a
great time and I was just thinking I
told Vito my filmer I was like yeah man
I can't do it and so I I push it out and
I was thinking about like not doing it
and so uh one of my friends canals uh he
has this one idea that I've been wanting
to do so I was like yo man do you want
to trade ideas and I told him my idea
about you know taking a nap at a WNBA
game and he sounded like super excited
about it and I was like damn like he
sounds like he really wants this one it
might be a banger it might be a banger
so I was like you know what I'm gonna do
it and so we did it and
I did feel bad but like I didn't
I thought it
people were the thing that like kind of
got me though is like people made it so
much more political than it really
needed to be like you mean political
like bro it was like somebody like
right-wing people using it as commentary
of like oh witness and stuff like that
and I was like bro and then there was so
many like left people and stuff like
that just call me misogynistic and
everything and it's like
just because you're trolling a little
bit doesn't mean you hate women right so
it was just like both sides but then
again like you know I should have
expected it but it was an thing
to do is there any any prank that you
didn't put out because you're like I
feel bad about this yeah I did one uh we
still got into the vote so it was
Valentine's Day and I flew this girl out
she does pranks
and we would go to like bars or
restaurants and I see a guy with his
girl and I would go up and be like yo
man that's a nice shirt bro what's your
name you're like oh my name's Jared I'll
be like oh you have a nice day Jared and
then I'll go up to the girl and I'll be
like his name is Jared and then she'll
come up and she'll be like Jared how you
doing I thought you weren't gonna be out
and then like
um
[Applause]
it's on the vote but uh that one's out
like damn but we got to train that with
all the couples and everything like they
thought what happened oh man bro I did
the worst one it was this uh Mexican
couple like uh she was she was like she
was 14.
she was pissed she was like she was
telling the girl you can go now you can
go and like you just see Brody like the
fit like he's just like talking to her
and stuff and I came up I was like yo
it's just the prank everything is all
good and then there was this black
couple we did it too and it was just
funny because she's a white girl and so
but like yeah
what happened what you say like
[Music]
[Laughter]
and everything and they're good but do
you offer to cover their dinner or
something yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
definitely definitely like I made it up
to them and stuff yeah where how do you
what do you mean you made it up to him
like I was like um
go out and do something and then the
black couple I bought them like two
rounds okay on me and stuff
[Laughter]
bro but why have you made it good with
all the couples why are you playing
that's what I'm wondering bro because
it's a prank so we did this one where um
I put on my story yeah that uh I was
like yo I need someone's Uber account
and someone came through and they gave
me their car and they gave me their Uber
account and I sent them GoPros and
everything so you were the driver I was
a driver and I got these Heinekens but
they were zero percent alcohol yeah and
I don't pick up people and um I was like
drinking the Heinekens while I was
driving I had these weird ass voice
memos and
um
I was just doing like the weirdest
and um I had one I had like this girl
call me and pretend that she was
cheating on me while the passenger in
the back is just listening to everything
and all those pranks I never told any of
them that it was a prank like every time
they got out like I didn't tell anybody
because I just feel like it's way
funnier like they're gonna be like bro
you won't believe what happened when I
was in my Uber and stuff like that you
know it's like a cool story and then
they see the video they see the video
but like I wanted to just be something
where it's just like oh man that was
crazy yeah the long game yeah yeah guys
tour announcements greater Toronto area
tickets are officially on sale for
Niagara Falls Ontario okay Fallsview
Casino we are coming the 22nd of
September then the 23rd of September
we're coming to Windsor Ontario that's
right the Coliseum at Caesars pull up
and Dublin Ireland we are coming to the
three Arena October 12th and of course
Calgary The Great Outdoors Fest I'll be
performing there August 27th get the
tickets for all those shows at the
andrewshows.com I cannot wait for you
guys to see this piece also guys we need
to announce some tour dates first of all
uh I'm going to be doing a residency in
New York City I keep getting hit up by
people in New York on the street saying
what are you doing a show here I'm going
to run my special four times August 7th
14th 21st and 28th at New York comedy
club so hurry up and buy tickets to that
because it is a small club and tickets
will sell out also August 2nd next week
I'm gonna be in Omaha Nebraska and the
next day I'm going to be in Des Moines
Iowa the bum ass cities tour trucks on
and I say trucks because there will be a
lot of them there also August 23rd I'm
gonna be in Indianapolis Indiana
naptown I'm coming to see you I'm pretty
sure it's called naptown also August
24th I'm gonna be in Louisville Kentucky
please don't be that racist toward me
anyway you can get your tickets for
those dates and more at Akash singh.com
now let's get back to the show there's a
there's this guy forget his name was
Andrew Zimmerman I probably told the
story of power before but uh do you
heard of him he's like Man Vs Food guy I
only know George's number man
probably related and uh and and he was
at he was he did this like food show
where he like found out we're all like I
think he would have to eat like this
crazy amount of food doesn't matter he
travels around the country uh-huh and we
saw him when we were recording podcasts
in like our old old studio and I was
like dude oh I've watched your show
you're the man like do you have any
recommendations for like places to go
eat in New York right yeah and he goes I
got three places for you there he goes
you go go to this one place called uh La
Loma or something like that and then you
ask for The Salted lamb or something
like this right he goes now if that
doesn't work out you can go to uh Five
Guys but go to the Five Guys on 14th
Street and and as for the off menu sushi
right and he goes if that doesn't work
out go to the Navy yards or something
like that and then go through all the
storage containers and then there's a
little Mexican restaurant on the storage
unit like oh but he said this here
but if you go to the Five Guys you need
to bring them a banana in order to order
from the off uh off menu sushi right
doing a banana the Five Guys me and
three boys at 12 p.m buy bananas
at a bodega right we first go to this uh
the La Luna one right we're like we want
the off menu salted lamb and they're
like we're a vegan restaurant there's no
and we're like yeah the off menu I don't
know what the you're talking about
so we're like oh that's kind of weird
all right maybe he messed it up then we
go to Bodega three of us buy bananas at
12 at night it looks like some super gay
is about to go down we're walking
down the street bananas we walk into
Five Guys right three guys command us
with five guys and we the waiter comes
up and I go we'll have the off menu
Sushi he goes I don't know what you're
talking about I go
like supposed to be like
though this is going
because
thanks man but I don't know what the
you're talking about I'm like you
tell me there's no sushi if I bring a
banana he's like no there's no
Sushi I've never spoken to him again
he's never talked about it again he just
pranked me for the sake of pranking me
yeah lucky that Five Guys employee was
white if it was a black dude Latino
um
why would you go to a Five Guys for
sushi that's that was why it was such a
good it was off menu bro no five napkins
not five guys
and then oh I never went to the last
button apparently that one's real
I was like the most purest form of a
prank I wouldn't be able to do that I
would need to like follow the person see
it happen and like get that satisfaction
because I'm used to stand up you know
it's like say the joke and get the
response but to do it knowing that
that's gonna happen and then never
reconnect with that person yeah
diabolic or the fact that you're on a
major podcast and you're gonna talk
about it and he's like maybe yeah
you just found out that you were
drinking fake Heinekens yeah amen I
don't with that drinking and
driving you're safe
[Laughter]
who's the best people to prank like when
you do pranks are you trying to get a
bunch of different like ethnic groups
and cultures and stuff you know how
David Blaine would only do the magic to
black people because they react to
craziest thing really yeah if you ever
watch street magic it's only to black
people
this is I think Aziz had a bit about
this but it's like it is a known thing
like all street magic is to black people
you can even see like black athletes too
still believe magic is real a little bit
like I'm being honest
they go crazy for it I mean watch you
find these treatment magician in America
that is going up to white people
I think the reaction is just more muted
right exactly yeah interesting I thought
it was an Ace of Spades yeah oh you got
my card great job I remember watching
David Blaine's first like special that
he put on like ABC or whatever and he
pranks the Dallas Cowboys back when they
were good I didn't see Emma Smith
celebrate that argument
so does that happen with pranks is there
a is there a metric for that no no um I
I really won't even consider what I do
really like just pranks because like we
just the camera be right there like half
times people just don't see it because
I'll just be talking about and
then like they'll like see the video and
they'll be like oh I don't even know I
was on camera
but what I love the most is like
whenever
um because sometimes like I'll have beef
with someone on the video and then like
I rekindle with them and then like we do
something cool like uh it's just
multiple people but that's what I like
the most what was the best version of
that the best version uh there's this
dude and the uh the Minnesota Mall of
America one yeah oh did you do something
with them and I was with this
like Irish
and then um like we just became cool and
they're like I came back and we did like
an art off and uh I think his ig's dirty
art hole yeah yeah and um yeah like that
stuff that's the fun he wanted to smoke
bro he did he was ready he was ready did
you get nervous at all
oh yeah like bro I'm not gonna lie like
bro if someone's a swing on me they have
every right to like I'm gonna just keep
it a buck I'm not gonna be that guy like
bro why'd you hit me like it's like I'm
with you yeah yeah like I
totally understand Bro you've invited
all the Smokies yeah I didn't like oh
I could hook off our video I get my
off
they might hit you preemptively I knew
you were gonna do something so I had to
swing on you oh yeah it'd be funny
because now like I'll be walking in the
stores just chilling and I'd be like nah
man you come here to with us I'm
just like no man I'm just shopping bro
that's interesting if you become too
famous to do the pranks
that's what happened to uh Tom Green do
you remember Tom Green yeah I see you as
like our our the younger Generations
version of the um
what is the provocateurs right like
every generation has like a provocateur
Sasha Sasha was it for a while Tom Green
was it for a while and this has gone you
know on every decade has this version
and I'm not familiar you don't know who
Tom Green is oh I think buddy we're old
I only knows you should look into Tom
Green isn't he the one that made uh The
Fault in Our Stars no I mean
further from whoever that is John Green
John Green NBA player like that's Jalen
green bro
no Tom Green Legend had an MTV show and
uh and he would like just prank his
parents prank everybody's family and
then he got so famous here he couldn't
do it so he just pranked Japan really
and he just went to Japan and they
didn't know who he was who could get
away with all the you see I want
and like I just want to wear like an NBA
jersey and wait to wear uh wear a beard
like a bigger beard and just like stand
around and like just have them all think
like I'm a basketball player
James Harden yeah
yeah I want to go to I want to go to
Japan so bad I love uh doing cultural
stuff like we went to Paris and we uh we
spent the night under the catacombs we
went to like the illegal part yeah and
we had this dude like he like just gave
us a tour all around it and like we saw
Nazi bunkers we like you'll see stuff
that was like in the 1900s then you'll
see stuff all the way in the 1600s whoa
and then there was just like skulls yeah
yeah you spent the night yeah yeah we
spent the entire night down there that
is wild uh uh I forgot the uh that did
the cataphiles or something like that
but like they like press they preserve
it down there yeah and like they take
care of it and um they're really cool
people they're really cool people and
then the next day we went to the Louvre
and I put a picture of myself of the
Mona Lisa right next to the Mona Lisa
and then I got arrested in Paris jail
I'm not gonna lie Paris jail is way
better than American Joe oh so you got
locked up locked up oh yeah for how long
like uh 24 hours yeah light
[Laughter]
I was the most anxious about that
because I was like damn I'm gonna be
like a Brittany grinder situation like
yeah just locked up but uh the
cops are really cool though uh when I
got arrested uh it was these cops and
rollerblades he got invested by a
rollerblade cop in France
but yeah rollerblades like this is
shooting and then you're rolling back
literally
literally like it was so intimidating at
first until you've seen the rollerblades
yeah but um the guy when I was in the
station he came up to me and he was like
he was like oh I like your uh I liked
your video and I was like oh which one
and he was like
and I was like what he's like
and I was like I was like I don't know
what you're talking about and then he
goes to my Ig and he shows my story I
had made a tick tock about uh me at the
um Eiffel Tower and I put the uh
in Paris instrumental in the background
he like showed me he's like
you just shut up say he said in
Paris the white guy the white guy
yeah
he thought you made the song he was like
dude you nailed it that's the nicest
thing that's the nicest a white cop has
ever said that word to a black guy yeah
they've used it it wasn't offended at
all I was just like why is French jail
better
oh man I they put me in a Cell by myself
and the food was way better yeah and um
French food huh French food yeah it was
like some like stew it was really good
yeah it was really really good best meal
you had in Paris oh man the food was
horrible
Paris food is horrible you were in jail
what are you talking about I don't get
food they don't get food yeah
where'd you go where'd you go to eat man
we just went to different restaurants
and stuff but like it's just not good in
Europe really at least
the UK oh the UK is even worse
from Texas like what even is that you
know yeah you're too seasoning all of
that southern that southern that soul
food
you be a soul food yeah of
course no you don't no I don't know
if I eat soul food I gotta nap two hours
before the show every time we go down
south and we have like a soul food
brunch it takes your soul it literally
takes the salt two hour nap before the
show if I'm Gonna Make It Happen yeah
all right so like I can ask you a
question I've been listening why pranks
I've heard a few interviews of you and I
haven't heard that because you're such a
sweet guy you always say I want the joke
to be on me and you do a good job of if
the joke isn't on you making it right
with the person but pranking is not
necessarily on you it's so I'm wondering
how like this sweet guy coming to let me
terrorize people and then now I'm
learning not even tell them half the
time
man oh I just been thinking of I guess
it's kind of like you guys are comedians
just like you guys will just be thinking
of bits in your head yeah and it's just
like I just be thinking of stuff and I'm
just like it's more like stuff that you
would say to your friends like damn that
would be funny but like I'm like let's
do it